The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: In the
last lecture, we
introduced an alternative
set of algorithms
for computation of the
fast Fourier transform
or rather, computation of the
discrete Fourier transform.
And we refer to these as
the decimation in frequency
form of the algorithm.
As you recall, we
developed the decimation
in frequency form
of the algorithm
by essentially organizing
the computation of the even
numbered DFT points and the odd
numbered DFT points separately
and then proceeded
in a similar manner.
This corresponded to breaking
the computation into two
and over two point DFT's
proceeded in a similar manner
to decompose the computation
of these separately
into their even numbered points
and odd numbered points, et
cetera.
And the flow graph that resulted
from this procedure was--
as I've shown here--
which is one form,
then, of the decimation
in frequency form of the fast
Fourier transform algorithm.
It begins with the data sorted
in normal order and proceeds
to the data sorted in
big reversed order.
And as I stressed
last time, it also
corresponds to an in-place
computation because of the way
in which the butterflies
are laid out.
In particular, the output
nodes for each butterfly
are horizontally adjacent
to the input nodes.
Now this is similar in
a number of respects
to one of the decimation in
time forms of the FFT algorithm.
Although, as I also
indicated last time,
the basic structure of
the butterfly computation
is somewhat different.
In particular, for
this set of algorithms,
the multiplication
by powers of W
is implemented at the
output of the butterfly,
as opposed to the
decimation in time forms,
where the multiplication
by powers of W
are implemented at the
input to the butterfly.
However, there is a
very close relationship
between this flow graph
and the original flow graph
that we implemented for the
decimation in time algorithm.
In particular, the
two flow graphs
are transposes of each other.
Now I remind you that in
one of the early lectures,
when we introduced the notation
of flow graphs and some
of the properties
of flow graphs,
one of the properties of flow
graphs that I mentioned--
although we didn't derive it--
was the fact that
transposition of a flow graph
doesn't change the input
output characteristics.
So then in fact, if we took
this flow graph, changed
the direction of
all of the arrows,
treated this set of
nodes as the input nodes
and this set of nodes
as the output nodes,
then since the flow graph,
as it's indicated here,
computes the discrete
Fourier transform,
the transposed flow
graph would also
compute the discrete
Fourier transform.
And in fact, the transposition
of this flow graph
is identical to the
first flow graph--
FFT flow graph--
that we introduced,
which was the initial
decimation in time form.
And that I refer
you to again, here.
So this is the
decimation in time form
of the algorithm with
the input bit reversed
and the output in normal order.
This is the transposition
of this flow graph, which
is the decimation in frequency
form of the algorithm
with the input in normal
order and the output in bit
reversed order.
The fact that these are
related through transposition
of the flow graph isn't a
particularly important point
from a practical point of view.
But it is a useful
piece of insight
into the relationship between
these various algorithms.
All right, now just as we
did with the decimation
in time forms of
the algorithm, we
can rearrange the decimation in
frequency form of the algorithm
to either arrange the output to
be in normal order, as opposed
to having the input
in normal order,
or rearrange it so that both
the input and output are
in normal order or
rearrange it as we will,
so that we can utilize
sequential memory rather
than random access memory.
To rearrange the flow
graph so that the output is
in normal order, we
would, again, simply
take horizontal lines
and re-sort them
so that the output nodes are
sorted in a normal order.
And the flow graph
that results is
a decimation in frequency
form of the algorithm,
for which the outputs
are in normal order.
But the inputs are in
bit reversed order.
Again, as this flow
graph has been sorted,
it is an in-place computation.
In-place, again, because
the butterflies are laid out
in such a way that they involve
horizontally adjacent nodes.
So this is an
in-place computation
with the input in
bit reversed order
and the output in normal order.
Again this is a transposition
of one of the flow graphs
that we discussed in
the previous lecture.
In particular, it is a
transposition of the flow graph
for which, if you imagine this
flow graph being transposed
so that the direction of
the arrows are reversed
and this is the input,
then it corresponds
to the decimation in time form
of the algorithm for which
the input is in normal order
and the output comes out
in bit reversed order.
And that is the flow graph
that I have indicated here.
So this is a decimation in time
form of the algorithm, which
is the transposition of
the decimation in frequency
form of the algorithm
that we just looked at.
All right, that corresponds
then to two possible decimation
in frequency algorithms.
One in which the input
is in normal order,
the output is bit reversed.
This one in which the input
is bit reversed and the output
is in normal order.
We can also rearrange
this so that the input is
in normal order and the
output is in normal order.
And the flow graph that
results when we implement that
is similar to the corresponding
decimation in time flow graph.
In fact, it is a transposition
of that flow graph.
And just as we found in the
decimation in time algorithm,
for this case, although the
input is sorted in normal order
and the output comes
out in normal order,
the indexing is
generally complicated
as we proceed from
stage to stage.
And furthermore, it
does not correspond
to an in-place computation,
because of the fact
that the outputs
of the butterflies
are no longer horizontally
adjacent to the inputs
to the butterfly.
So generally, this flow
graph and its decimation
in time counterpart are not
practically very important.
A final rearrangement
of the flow graph
is the rearrangement
which permits
the use of sequential memory
rather than random access
memory.
And this, then,
is the flow graph
that is the counterpart
to the flow graph
that we discussed last
time, which I referred to
as the Singleton algorithm,
or I attributed to Singleton.
This is a variation of
that type of algorithm,
in which now, again, we
recognize that the indexing is
identical from stage to stage.
The input is in normal order.
And the output comes out
in bit reversed order.
And let me just
compare this for you
with the corresponding
flow graph
that we had last time,
which I've indicated here.
That has the input
in bit reversed
order, the output
in normal order.
In fact, the transposition
of this flow graph
is the decimation
in frequency form
of the algorithm, for which
the input is in normal order,
and the output is in
bit reversed order.
All right, so the indexing is
identical from stage to stage.
And just as we
had previously, we
can implement this
algorithm by utilizing
sequential memory as opposed
to random access memory.
Although the organization of
the memory for the decimation
in frequency form of
the Singleton algorithm
is somewhat different
than the organization
of the memory for the decimation
in time form of the Singleton
algorithm.
In particular, last time when
we discussed the decimation
in time algorithm, we had four
memories, as we will this time.
The first half of
the data in memory A,
the second half of
the memory in memory
B. We went, first of all,
through all of memory A,
then through all of memory B,
storing results alternatively
in memories C and D.
In this case, the strategy
in utilizing the memory
is somewhat different.
In this case, we store the first
half of the data points, again,
in memory A, the
second half of the data
points, again, in memory
B. But notice that now
in the computation utilizing
the computation for this point,
for example, we use the first
output point from memory A
and the first output
point from memory b.
We store the result in the
first register in memory C
and in the second
register in memory C.
Then, to compute
the next two points,
we take the next
point from memory A
and the next point
from memory B,
do the appropriate addition
and subtraction, multiplication
by powers of W, and store
those in the next two registers
in memory C. For this
particular example,
namely n equals eight,
that fills up memory C.
And we proceed, likewise,
accessing the input data,
alternating between
the two input memories
and storing data first in all
of one of the output memories
and then in all of the second
of the output memories.
And then we proceed in that
fashion from stage to stage.
But again, one of
the important aspects
is that it utilizes
sequential memory,
for example, disk or drum or
tape or shift register memory.
OK, so this then is
essentially a picture
of a variety of the
algorithms, which
can be used for the computation
of the discrete Fourier
transform, some of
which were derived
on the basis of a
decimation in time argument.
Some were derived on the basis
of a decimation in frequency
argument.
But we saw, in fact, that the
decimation in frequency forms
of the algorithm are,
in terms of flow graph
notation or
interpretation, transposes
of the decimation in time form.
What I would like
to discuss now are
a few of the
computational issues that
are involved in the implementing
the fast Fourier transform
algorithm and return, also, to
a brief discussion of at least
one situation in which
there is a preference
for using decimation in time or
using decimation in frequency.
After we've discussed
some of the computational
considerations, I will then
just very briefly discuss
the generalization of the fast
Fourier transform algorithm
to situations in which
the number of data points
is not a power of
two, but is a more
arbitrary composite number.
Well first of all,
then, let me introduce
a few of the
computational issues
that I would like to
draw your attention to.
The first is-- and it's a point
that I raised in the first
lecture, in which I introduced
the fast Fourier transform
algorithm--
that whereas our discussion
has been directed entirely
toward the computation
of the DFT,
it applies also, in a
very straightforward way,
to a computation
of the inverse DFT.
In particular, we know that
the inverse discrete Fourier
transform relationship is given
by 1 over N times the sum of x
of k W sub-N to the minus NK.
In contrast to the discrete
Fourier transform--
that is the forward transform--
which does not have
the factor of 1 over N
and involves multiplication by
W sub-N to the plus NK, rather
than W sub-N to the minus NK.
To use the algorithms
that we have just
been discussing
for the computation
of the inverse discrete
Fourier transform,
the modification is
relatively straightforward.
First of all, it
involves a factor of 1
over N, which we can
accommodate in a number of ways.
One is, of course, by
shifting the output
or by applying scaling at each
stage of the FFT, for example.
So this factor of 1 over
N is easily accommodated.
And the other difference
is the inclusion
of a minus sign in the
exponent in powers of W
rather than a plus sign
for the forward transform.
That means, in essence,
that these coefficients
are the complex conjugate
of these coefficients.
Because W sub-capital N is e
of the J two pi over capital N.
This minus sign represents
a conjugation of W.
And so one procedure that we
can follow for implementing
the inverse discrete Fourier
transform using all of the flow
graphs that we've talked
about is simply conjugate
the powers of W that are
involved in the computation.
An alternative procedure,
which is basically equivalent,
is to use the flow graphs
as they stand, in which case
the output data,
which is obtained,
is the desired result with
little n replaced by minus n.
So we can either
compute the inverse DFT
from an algorithm, which is
aimed at the forward DFT,
by conjugating the
coefficients or equivalently
by essentially flipping the
output, modulo capital N. So
all of the algorithms that
we have talked about, then,
relate in a very
straightforward manner
to the computation of the
inverse discrete Fourier
transform.
The second issue
is that as we've
seen in essentially
all of the algorithms
of practical interest, they
involve either bit reversal
at the input to the flow graph
or a bit reversal at the output
of the flow graph.
Bit reversal, again, is a
relatively straightforward
thing to implement.
First of all, it is important to
recognize that bit reversal is
an in-place computation, if we
think of it as a computation.
In particular, suppose that we
had the seven data indices zero
through seven.
And we want to rearrange
this data so that the data is
arranged in bit reversed order.
Well that means that, of course,
zero bit reversed is zero,
one bit reversed is four.
But of course, four
bit reversed is one.
So in fact, we would
want to store data
with whose index is one
in storage location four.
But we will also want to
store data whose data index
is four in storage location one.
So in fact, implementing
the bit reversal
can be accomplished in place
by essentially swapping
these two pieces of data.
Similarly of course,
two bit reverses two.
And so that wouldn't move.
Three bit reversed is six.
But six bit reversed is three.
And so again, we can
carry out that interchange
as an in-place computation.
So bit reversal, then, can
be implemented in place.
And consequently, as
we restore the data
in a bit reversed
order, we don't
require double the storage,
since we can carry that out
as an in-place operation.
Second of all, to implement
bit reversal, of course,
to implement bit reversal
in hardware, to obtain a bit
reversed index and
hardware is very simple.
We just simply rearrange
the order of the wires.
To implement a bit reversed
index register or an index
algorithmically is a little
more difficult. But in fact--
and this is discussed in some
more detail in the text--
one of the most
straightforward procedures,
normally, is to
implement a bit reversed
counter so that as we
proceed along with an index
register accessing through
an index in normal order,
we can also run a counter that
runs in bit reversed order
and use, essentially, those two
as index registers to tell us
how to swap the data.
So a bit reversal, in
fact, algorithmically
is relatively straightforward.
It's an interesting point that
it is a somewhat inefficient
procedure, as you'll see if you
try to program bit reversal.
But algorithmically
and conceptually,
it's a fairly straightforward
procedure to implement.
A third computational
issue, which
I would like to draw
your attention to
is the question of obtaining the
coefficients to use in the FFT
computation.
And there are basically
two procedures
that are commonly used.
One, of course, is to store
the coefficients in a table
and then simply access
them as they're needed.
A second, which saves
storage but requires
some computational time, is
to generate the coefficients
recursively.
That is essentially
using an oscillator--
programming an oscillator--
and generating the
coefficients as they're needed.
Along those lines, it's
interesting to observe
that in both the decimation
in time and decimation
in frequency forms
of the algorithm,
as you proceed from
stage to stage,
the powers of W that are
involved in the computation
are powers of a basic
power of W that doubles--
or at least that changes--
in each stage as you go
through the computation.
And this has
implications as you think
of either storing a table of
coefficients and accessing them
or as you think of generating
the coefficients recursively.
The fact that the powers of W
are related from stage to stage
suggests some fairly efficient
procedures for doing this.
One additional
consideration, though,
in obtaining the
coefficients is that
in some of the forms
of the FFT algorithm,
the coefficients are naturally
accessed in a normal order,
whereas in some other forms,
they are naturally accessed
in a bit reversed order.
For example, if we think of
the decimation in frequency
form of the algorithm,
here is the decimation
in frequency form
of the algorithm
with the input in normal
order and the output in bit
reversed order.
Notice that the powers of W
that we have here occur in what
looks like normal order.
At least these powers
are in normal order.
And this is normal input order,
bit reversed output order.
Whereas if we took,
let's say, the decimation
in time form of the algorithm--
where we have normally ordered
input and bit reversed output--
in that case, if you look
at these powers of W,
they're not in normal order.
In fact, what they're in
is bit reversed order.
So in fact, in addition
to the consideration
as to whether the
input is bit reversed
or the output is bit reversed,
in some forms of the algorithm,
the coefficients would tend
to be stored in normal order,
whereas in some other
forms of the algorithm,
the coefficients
would tend to be
stored in a bit reversed order.
Or if we think about
generating the coefficients,
clearly it is simpler to think
of generating coefficients
in normal order
than it is to think
of them as being generated
in bit reversed order.
Now with regard to the question
of the input and output
being bit reversed, one
important area in which
the computation of the DFT--
in other words, the
FFT algorithms--
play a role is in implementing
convolution or correlation.
In that case, we
compute a transform,
multiply by something-- in
the case of a convolution,
we multiply by the transform
of the impulse response--
and then implement
an inverse transform.
Well the fact that there
are two transforms involved
suggests the possibility that
we can organize the computation
in such a way that we
completely avoid bit reversal.
For example, we can
choose an algorithm
for the direct
transform, which utilizes
the input in normal order and
generates the transform in bit
reversed order.
We then simply
have the transform
of the impulse response stored
in bit reversed order, carry
out the multiplication,
and then choose
a form of the algorithm for
the inverse transform, which
has bit reversed
input and results
in a normally ordered output.
So in that case, what we would
have is the forward transform,
normally ordered data
being transformed
to bit reversed data.
And then as the
inverse transform,
bit reversed input and
normally ordered output.
Well even given that, there are
a number of options available.
For example, we
have an algorithm--
the decimation in
time algorithm--
which is normally ordered input.
I'm sorry, normally ordered
input and bit reversed
output, which we could use
as our forward transform.
Although as we just
illustrated, it
involves bit reversed
coefficients.
Well we could think of storing
the coefficients in bit
reversed order and then using
the companion decimation
in time form of the algorithm,
which has bit reversed input
and normally ordered output, to
achieve the inverse transform.
However, in this
case the coefficients
are in normal order.
So if we match up the
algorithms that way,
then we're faced
with the problem
that in the direct transform,
the coefficients would
be stored in bit
reversed order, whereas
in the inverse
transform they would
be stored in normal order.
Well you can ask whether
for the decimation
of frequency form of the
algorithm, we can avoid that.
But in fact, the same
problem arises there.
If we have the
decimation in time
in frequency form of the
algorithm with normal input,
bit reversed output,
then the coefficients
are stored in normal order.
But for the inverse decimation
in frequency transform with bit
reversed input and
normally ordered output,
the coefficients would be
stored in bit reversed order.
The solution is to
match up a decimation
in time form of the algorithm
with a decimation in frequency
form of the algorithm
so that, for example,
we can choose as the
forward transform
the decimation in frequency form
of the algorithm with the input
in normal order, the output
in bit reversed order,
and the coefficients
normally ordered,
which is generally
more convenient.
And then choose for the inverse
transform not the decimation
in frequency algorithm, but the
decimation in time algorithm,
for which the input
is now bit reversed,
the output is in normal
order, and the coefficients
are also in normal order.
So in fact, this suggests
that if we are implementing
a forward transform and
an inverse transform,
generally there are
advantages to matching up
the decimation in time form
and the decimation in frequency
form so that we have similarly
accessed coefficients
in both cases.
Well there are, of
course, a large variety
of other computational
issues to be
considered in implementing
the fast Fourier transform
algorithms.
Some of these are
discussed in the text.
Many of them you will
discover for yourselves
as you try to program
the algorithm.
But hopefully, this
discussion provides
at least some indication of
what some of the strategies are
and some of the issues
are that are involved
in computation of
the FFT of the forms
that we've been talking about.
Now all of this
discussion has been
related to the computation
of the discrete Fourier
transform when the number of
data points is a power of two.
And these algorithms are
referred to as the radix two
forms of the FFT algorithm.
As I indicated in the first
lecture, in which we discussed
the FFT, the FFT, in
fact, is more general
in that it generally
applies when
N is a highly composite number.
We chose it to be
composed of powers of two.
But in fact, there are
a variety of other forms
of the FFT algorithm
for different radices.
And in some cases, there
are some advantages
to be found in using not
a power of two algorithm,
but a different algorithm.
On the other hand,
in many situations,
the disadvantages of that
outweigh the advantages.
However, what I would like to
do is conclude the discussion
of the fast Fourier
transform algorithm
by just very briefly outlining
what the structure of the FFT
algorithm is more generally.
And again, in the text
there are a number
of examples of FFT
algorithms for radices
other than a power of two and
a more complete discussion
than I feel that is appropriate
to go through right now.
However, let me just outline
what some of the issues
are in discussing a more
general radix FFT algorithm.
Generally the computation
of the discrete Fourier
transform using this
class of algorithms
is directed toward
capitalizing on the fact
that the size transform
to be implemented
is a product of numbers.
And it turns out that
the more numbers--
the more terms in
the decomposition--
the greater the efficiency
that can be obtained
in implementing the transform.
In that case, generally one
would think of these numbers
as primes, since
that is the biggest
decomposition of any number
that we can carry out.
But in fact, for the derivation,
it is not a requirement
that the p's be primes.
So let's think of N, then,
as decomposed as a product
of p1 times p2, et
cetera, through p sub-Nu,
which we can alternatively
write as p1 times q1,
where q1 is then represented
by the product of the remaining
terms.
And we can proceed,
essentially, along a root
similar to the decimation in
time algorithms or along a root
similar to the decimation
in frequency algorithms.
Let me just indicate
the strategy paralleling
the decimation in time
form of the algorithm,
as we discussed that
for N, a power of two.
In that case, we decomposed
p1 is equal to two,
and q1 is equal to N over two.
And we decompose the
original sequence
into two sub-sequences,
one consisting
of the even numbered
points, the other consisting
of the odd numbered points.
More generally, we would
decompose the sequence
into a set of sub-sequences
consisting of every p1th point.
So how many sequences are there?
Well, there are p1 sequences.
And the length of
each sequence is q1.
For example, if p1 was equal
to two, and q1 was N over two,
this would be every other point.
That's choosing the
even numbered points
and the odd numbered points.
There would be
two sub-sequences,
each sub-sequence of
length N over two.
More generally, then, if
we had, say, N equal to 12,
and p1 equal to three, we would
generate three sub-sequences,
each consisting of four points
chosen by selecting every p1th,
or every third point.
So one sub sequence, which
I've denoted here by A,
would be this point and this
one and this one and that one.
The second sub-sequence
would be the sub-sequence B,
which is comprised of this
point, this, this, and that.
And the third sub-sequence
would be sub-sequence
C, which is this point,
this point, that point,
and that point.
All right, so we decompose
the original sequence, then,
into p1 sequences,
each of length q1.
Given that, we can
organize the sum involved
in the discrete
Fourier transform
by decomposing the sum
into separate sums,
involving each one of
these p1 sub-sequences.
In particular, if we think
of the argument p1 times
r, as r ranges from
zero to q1 minus one,
we're selecting, with this
argument, every p1th point,
starting with the
zero-eth point.
If we think of the
argument p1 r plus one,
as r runs from zero
to q1 minus one,
we're then collecting
together the terms,
which are every p1th point,
starting with the first point.
Et cetera, we can
proceed to decompose this
into a set of p1 sub-sums,
as I've indicated here.
Or when we combine
these together,
then, we can express
x of k, the DFT,
as a double sum, where we
have the terms involving
the separate sub sequences
and then the multiplication
by a power of W to
combine the computation
on these sub-sequences
together to obtain the DFT.
These terms, of course,
are obtained by the fact
that this power of
W is p1 r plus one.
In the next sum, it will be p1
r plus two, p1 r plus three,
et cetera.
We decompose that into a
product of two powers of W.
And then one of those terms--
since it doesn't
depend on r-- can
be removed from the sum on r
and shows up in this second sum.
Well I would suggest--
that's a somewhat
rapid treatment--
I would suggest
just simply working
through that for an example.
And I think it will be clear how
this original sum is decomposed
into this one.
All right, well now, just as
we did in both the decimation
in time and decimation
in frequency forms
of the algorithm
for powers of two,
we can recognize
this power of W sub-N
as a different power of a W
with a different subscript.
In particular, W sub-N to
the p1 rk, as I have here,
is equal to e to the j two pi
over capital-N times p1 rk.
But N is equal to p1 times q1.
That's the way we
originally decomposed it.
And the p1's cancel out.
And we're left with e to
the j two pi over q1 times
rk or equivalently,
W sub-q1 to the rk.
So substituting this
for W sub-N to the p1 r
k in the previous expression,
what results is then x of k
expressed as a sum from l
equals zero, p1 minus one,
of these powers of
W sub-N. But then
the important thing is that
the inner sum involves q1 point
sequences.
This factor is W
sub-q1 to the rk.
And in fact, this entire
summation is a q1 point DFT.
So pursuing this, then,
what we basically decomposed
the computation into is the
computation of p1 q1 point
DFT's.
We obtained the q1 point
DFT's and then combined them,
according to the
expression as we have here.
This would then lead to the
generalization of the butterfly
computation as we had it for
the radix two algorithms.
And if you count up the
number of multiplies and adds,
again, you'll see that there is
some computational efficiency
that results from doing this.
And then, just as we did with
the radix two algorithms,
we can continue to
decompose these transforms
so that we have q1 is given
by the product p2 times p3
through p sub-Nu.
This product we denote as q2.
And then we can proceed to
decompose these transforms--
these q1 point transforms--
into p2 q2 point transforms.
Then we can decompose the q2
point transforms, et cetera.
If you do this, then
what you'll find--
and the counting is done
a little more carefully
in the text--
what you'll find is that the
number of multiplies and adds
involved in computing the
discrete Fourier transform
this way is proportional to
N times a sum of the factors
involved in the
decomposition of N.
I've indicated an additional
factor here of minus Nu.
Depending on how you choose
to count multiplies and adds,
this factor of minus Nu
either shows up or not.
In fact, to make this
expression consistent with what
we obtained for the
power of two algorithms,
the minus Nu should be in here.
And it's simply a
question of whether you
count or don't count some
multiplications by unity.
Well OK, that's a very quick
treatment-- discussion--
of the generalization of
the radix two algorithms
to more arbitrary radix.
And there, as I indicated,
are some examples
of this, which are
given in the text.
Although, in fact,
what you'll find
is that in most
practical contexts,
it is a radix two algorithm that
is the most efficient to use.
And I indicate,
incidentally, that if you
are faced with the problem
of transforming data, which
is of a length which is not
a power of two, it of course
can always be made to be
of length power of two
by simply augmenting
the sequence with zeros.
Well this concludes, then,
the discussion of the FFT
algorithms, the computation of
the discrete Fourier transform.
And there are, I hope,
a number of issues
which you will
have an opportunity
to dwell on some as you
read through the text
and as your attention will be
drawn to in the study guide.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]